this had been brewing for 16 years
[Applause]
the glazers have never been popular
owners but their part in the super
league plot
meant this was on another level
the police described it as atrocious six
officers were injured
one suffered facial wounds another was
left with a fractured eye socket
and it forced one of the biggest games
in world football
to be called off listen i'm not going to
condole violence games police officers
but there were thousands of people here
protesting yesterday of what i gathered
was it two injuries or something like
that so it's a very small percent of
people that were here that were causing
any trouble the vast vast majority of
united fans here were here to protest to
get a reaction to make an impact
and to send a message to the glazers and
i think the message was sent
manchester united have denied that fans
have been let into the ground
and said some smashed their way in now
within 24 hours
the football authorities have acted the
premier league
acknowledging the anger and tightening
their ownership rules
for clubs in principle we certainly
welcome it and i think the other
extraordinary thing about the premier
league statement is that they're
quote enlisting the support of
government for legislation to
protect the football pyramid which we
would certainly
support but one former chairman of the
fa
argues it's the premier league model
that's part of the problem
the premier league is 20 separate
businesses
coming together to sell their rights
together by any other
in any other industry that would be
called a cartel
now is the opportunity now that the big
six
uh on the back foot now is the
opportunity
for government to actually do something
while the glazer issue is specific to
manchester united
there is simmering anger at the other
clubs who'd want a piece
of the super league their rivals at
manchester city
are enjoying their own success but also
want change
both parties well all parties need to
understand that
this is getting ridiculous they have to
act they have to
legislate for the football industry
football is grappling with a
far-reaching question
how do you give the supporters the
lifeblood of every club
a real say in the running of a
multi-billion pound
global business tom parmenter sky news
manchester